you
my guest this week is a writer for
Breitbart calm and a general rabble
rouser and Renaissance man milo i
innopolis welcome to the show thanks so
much for having me so when i tweeted out
originally that you were coming in half
the people told me i was going to
absolutely hate you half the people told
me i was gonna love you the first awful
wrong the first half wrong yeah alright
so so we actually had a drink the other
night want to be totally transparent
here we had a drink the other night and
we talked a little bit so we've gotten
to know each other however much you can
in an hour you are a gay conservative
mm-hmm
now I want to repeat that just so that
the audience can be clear you are a gay
you think it eats repeat so you think
it's weird conservative with people
people would that be strange well people
freaked out so let's let's just let's
just start what is a conservative to you
in 2015 because I think people don't
even know what sort of basic terms
anymore much less the gay part but let's
just what is it conservative I think the
reason people surprised about a gay
conservative is because and we have a
slightly outdated notion of what
conservatism is now and the religious
right America doesn't have the same
purchase on the public imagination
anymore that it once did so it's a sort
of part of the right but not whole of it
and the right in Europe is drifting
quite quickly to the left so depth of
conservatism as a movement as political
philosophy is a bit lost at the moment
one thing we can say for sure is that
people on both sides of the political
spectrum are moving toward a sort of
center-right libertarianism and for me
the big gap between people the the big
sort of defining political schism
particularly on the internet but I think
of everybody really is not left and
right anymore it's becoming between
authoritarians and libertarians the
issue for the left being that there
isn't much space for libertarians there
a lot of conservatives who you know
don't know unnecessary religious or find
their own party drifting to the left are
beginning to call themselves
conservative begin call themselves
libertarians or conservatory and so I
think it's a more interesting
distinction to speak in terms of
personal liberty and freedom now and
when you understand it like that it
makes much more sense why gay person
would be one right so the part that we
sort of fall out on the same spot is the
authoritarian and libertarian part of
this right right we don't like the
authoritarians I think both of us are
sort of libertarians libertarians are
thought more of in the conservative
space
but if you were to give me like a three
sentence synopsis of when you say to
someone I'm a conservative what do you
what are the principles there what is
what is the basic bullet principles I
think you believe in individual opponent
personal responsibility you believe in
freedom of thought of expression of
creativity you believe in free markets
you believe that the relationship the
individual the state should be
circumscribed quite clearly and quite
crisply so you believe that state has a
limited and quite well-defined set of
responsibilities beyond which it should
not stretch you believe in the power and
value of institution and authority and
community structures so you believe that
even if you may for example believe that
even if you're not a Christian you still
recognize that the church has something
to offer that is a valuable institution
that keep that makes we walk into that
we'll go today okay um but it likewise
institutions like monarchy you respect
them because you understand that even
though for example it would be very
difficult to defend the monarchy in
purely logistical purely logical terms
these days nonetheless it works best in
Britain it is the best system yet
devised and it works brilliantly in
Britain even if you if you were to
design a state today you wouldn't come
up with it and consider all out of the
car vendors or even services we on the
rock are there they're obviously wrong
conservatives instinctively understand
the value of tradition and authority and
and of course liberals want to tear all
those things down so I think those are
some of the things that people mean when
they describe themselves as a
conservative right so the reason I think
it's it's sort of a confusing term or
that all our terms have become confusing
I think is because a lot of times now as
you sort of alluded to in America we
think of conservatives somehow as a
detachment to the religious right which
is weakened a little bit which i think
is good and you're saying in England
it's a little more of a respect for the
monarchy monarchy as respect for
traditions but I think a lot of people
would say well you're just in it for the
man right well I think it's preposterous
so if you look at the number look at how
many working-class conservative voters
there are why would all of these people
be voting against their own interests if
that were true you know if conservatism
were really about protecting rich people
why would millions of people who
struggle to make rent or struggle to put
their kids through college or struggle
even perhaps to you know to feed their
families vote conservative they do it
because they appreciate the value
of some of the structures around that
they love and they do it because they
they believe in a certain you know limit
of the states power they believe in
other things that go with conservatism
you why would so many people vote
against their interest in this absurd
characterization it's a childish
characterization of conservatism to
suggest that it is you know in some way
just a system to protect them and
protect the rich to protect corporations
I think we can all agree that
corporatism and mature late capitalism
which exists in too intricate symbiosis
with the private sector and in some
cases quite poisonous in that respect
the bailouts of the banks in the UK the
sorts of corporate cronyism it happens
in all right many have it here too right
of course I think we all agree that's a
bad thing but it is by no means
restricted to one side of the political
spectrum yeah well I always say there's
a reason that at least in America you
know the 1% give basically 51% to the
Republicans and 49% to the Democrats
because they're they're hedging their
bets so yeah I don't believe it goes
down to either party I don't you know if
you if you take the view that
conservatism is about you know sticking
up for the man you have to explain
things like why conservatives give more
money to charity
why even conservatives who aren't
religious give more to charity there are
a lot of very difficult questions you
have to answer if you want to make that
argument for me it doesn't hold water
you